[Musique]
le grand écrivain et comme la grêle qui
nourrit les autres de ceux qui la
nourrit d'abord elle même
je me réjouis pour toi de cette
rencontre avec et ce tir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un métier avec proust une émission de
lowrie maquis bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' envies de lecture bonjour
nathalie vol
ça coûtait bassett générique d'une
émission de notre invité lors al makki
l'été il y avait cet arrêté avec elle
avait un et avec outils en été avec
victor hugo également un c'est à dire
que on va on va parler d'elle mais c'est
vrai qu'elle est écrivain à kelly adore
aussi des autres écrivent tout à fait
bonjour laura elle maquille merci
beaucoup on joue avec nous aujourd'hui
merci me recevoir oui ce petit extra une
façon de vous présenter voilà de parler
de votre passion des écrivains comme
vient de dire patrice vous êtes donc
écrivain vous même auteur d'un certain
nombre de biographies hsg ouest auront
également ou encore la belle de graphie
consacré aux soeurs brontë vous enseigne
à sciences po dans le cadre de
séminaires d'écriture et vous êtes
également traductrice
on va y revenir tout à l'heure mêlant
laurent avant de parler de votre dernier
livre les incomprise
un mot sur ce genre particulier qu'est
la biographie on n'écrit pas une
biographie comment on écrit un roman et
un important travail de recherche
préalable qui est nécessaire alors
l'horreur maquis racontez nous ce qui
vous anime dans ce type d'écriture est
ce qu'il ya des écueils à éviter est ce
qu'il ya des règles à respecter
et bien quand quand on raconte la vie
d'un homme ou d'une femme remarquable
n'y a aucune règle à respecter parce
qu'en littérature il n'y a pas de règle
et heureusement en revanche moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui résiste à la
vie c'est ce qui dépasse peut-être la
simple chronologie les événements les
actions les paroles con con qu'on sait
qu'on connaît de certains personnages
moi ce qui m'intéresse ce sont les zones
d'ombré qui n'a pas été dit est ce qui a
pourtant été vécue et la l'écriture
intervient et le personnage peut entrer
en littérature
je pense que ce qui est c'est ce qui
distingue un biographe de remonter en
historien
c'est que le biographe peut aller du
côté de la fiction sans pour autant être
dans le roman complet mais en tout cas
il se détache du factuel il essaye de
d'inventer une manière de raconter cette
vie et c'est ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
dans ce genre et je le vois tous les
jours quand je vais en librairie et ils
sont ouvertes et c'est tant qu il ya de
plus en plus de deux livres sur ce genre
qui m'ont multiples il y à mille
manières de raconter la vie des autres
et je pense que c'est un genre vraiment
inépuisable la vie des autres voilà
c'est alors c'est l'islande est
incomprise en eau pourrait parler plus
de portraits que deux biographies propre
rebond proprement dit hier aux femmes
que vous avez choisi puis 11 extrait
également de leurs écrits tu as dit que
vous avez écrit avec pierre grillet qui
est auteur de chansons notamment
il a écrit pour bachelot il a écrit pour
vanessa paradis entre autres et s'est
illustré alors là on s'attendait pas à
sa faim moi je m'attendais pas par atik
rahimi qu'il est con côté comme écrit
maps quel était le prix goncourt 2008
pour ça vous voyez sabour pierre de
patience donc c'est quelqu'un qui a tous
les talents
comment vous avez procédé à trois comme
ça comment comment est venue l'idée de
travailler tous les trois ensemble
au départ l'idée a été travaillé avec
avec pierre parce que pierre a eu ce
cette idée de deux portraits de femmes
mais il voulait d'abord le le porter sur
scène
et puis bon la pandémie est arrivé et on
s'est retrouvés tous un peu chez nous
donc on s'est dit qu'on allait écrire un
livre et atic que je je connais que nous
connaissons avec pierre était lui aussi
un peu désoeuvrés avec cette situation
l'année dernière qui nous a qui nous un
pays mobilisé et il nous a proposé on
lui a proposé de s'associer au projet et
atic est un grand écrivain mais aussi un
grand artiste
il s'est usé du calame et il a fait
c'est magnifique esquisse je parle des
skis ce parce que j'aime j'aime beaucoup
comment il a interprété le titre
et cette manière qu'il a eue de garder
du vide dans ces visages ça traduit
exactement je pense qu'on a voulu faire
avec pierre c'est-à-dire essayé de
débaucher des femmes qui resteront de
toute façon un mystère qui résiste à la
compréhension
et justement ces héroïnes laura on les
découvre par leur prénom
pourquoi d'ailleurs nicky et non pas
niki de saint phalle ou françoise et paf
françois giroux c'est une façon
peut-être d'entrer dans leur intimité
oui tout à fait leur intimité je ne sais
pas en tout cas alors leur antériorité
essayé j'ai essayé moi dans les
portraits de me positionner aussi ici on
parle de technique un peu en terme de
points de vue papa corneau mini sciences
mais aussi de de m'interroger de me
demander
elle avait dans l'eure dans leur tête
donc oui démarrer commencer par leur
prénom c'est aussi commencer par par
l'humain par les émotions à re par ce
qui fait une vie mais en tout cas du
côté de l'ombre vous voyez ces femmes
elles sont célèbres
elles sont célèbres par leur nom mais
pas par leur prénom donc l'idée là
c'était vraiment d'être du côté de leur
féminité de leur intériorité de savoir
ce qui se jouait en elle là c'est aux
femmes justement on va on va parler un
peu de vos choix
nicky niki de saint phalle côtoient
vidéo d'idées qui côtoie elle-même
louise michel qui quoi toi françoise 0
qui la voisine de simone veil si vous ne
faites pas philosophe femmes politiques
qui précède elle-même
amy winehouse alors on voit bien venir
un vous dites sel sont incomprises mais
au fond la compréhension on peut se dire
ce que c'est pas un peu va saab après
tout est ce que nous on est pas tous des
incompris est ce que il n'y aurait pas
pu y avoir beaucoup d'autres femmes qui
pouvaient retrait donc dans cette
catégorie là alors oui la route non
seulement des femmes et peut-être
désormais effectivement vous avez tout à
fait raison sous unix et pas du tout un
très finement et je l'espère en tout cas
tout est parti d'une phrase d'une
intuition qui s'est forgée autour d'une
phrase de marilyn monroe qui dit dans
ces fragments de journaux intimes qui
sont absolument magnifiques et qui sont
à lire
et aujourd'hui disponible heureusement
français qui dit que voilà peu importe
ce que je dis comment je les dis qui je
suis c'est ma vérité même quand c'est un
conflit et avec cette phrase on s'est
ressaisi mais c'est intéressant ce
combat pour être soi et c'est très
inattendu de la part de marion monroe
qui a été houleux c'est très définis par
le regard des autres et maryline nous a
fait penser tout d'un coup à amy
winehouse qui elle aussi était une sorte
d'icône il ya quelques années
complètement poursuivi par parce par ce
regard d'autrui qui l'a littéralement
détruit et me voient de race nous a fait
penser à ces binage prime et puis on est
allés du côté de sylvia plath qui nous a
amenés vers emily dickinson
au fond on a fonctionné un peu un rebond
sans savoir vraiment où on allait en
suivant cette intuition qu'il y avait
une sorte de famille d'un comprise des
femmes indépendantes
insatisfaite profondément un tranquille
mais libre et qui ont essayé de se
définir à part des autres et ça c'était
quelque chose qui nous a qui nous a
vraiment fasciné j'étais certaine
rudesse trafic vous parler d'amy
winehouse ou de marilyn monroe
doutre peut-être cette incompréhension
et l'eau peut plus cacher je pense la
france aussi où on pourrait se dire vu
de l'extérieur comme ça elle a eu quand
même une grande réussite dans sa vie
alors oui c'est intéressant le premier à
françois giroux comme exemple parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui a été politiquement
extrêmement 20 juillet soit le seul
devant de la scène qui a laissé son nom
sur plusieurs lois et en même temps
aujourd'hui elle reste dans l'esprit de
certaines femmes comme comme une femme
voilà dont on ne comprend pas certains
choix françoise giroud là elle elle n'a
jamais hésité à dire que le premier
enfant qu'elle a eue elle n'était pas
heureuse d'avoir sept enfants elle a été
on le sait à la fois quelqu'un qui
promeut les femmes au sein du milieu
professionnel et en même temps qui leur
en veux quand elles veulent par exemple
fonder une famille
récupérer leur liberté donc françois
giroux est une femme extrêmement
complexe parce qu'elle a elle avait elle
ses désirs ses rêves qu'elle a voulu
peut-être imposer aux autres un peu trop
fort dont françois giroud à la fois oui
c'est une grande réussite mais tout
d'ailleurs
elles se sont toutes réalisées alors
effectivement publiquement pas mais
elles sont toutes devenues à leur
manière elles mêmes mais reste
aujourd'hui une part d'elle qu'on ne
peut pas saisir cette incompréhension il
y à la société et notamment une société
longtemps dirigé par les hommes vous
consacrez d'ailleurs un chapitre adèle
hugo que son père victor hugo a fait
enfermer ce qui est peut-être aussi la
preuve que cet immense auteur des
misérables a aussi sa part d'ombré
oui alors c'est une femme chère à mon
coeur
ll mais buzz depuis plusieurs années
elle nous bouleverse littéralement son
silence la voix ou qu'elle n'a pas fait
entendre pendant pendant plusieurs
années et pourtant ces milliers de pages
écrites ce journal intime foisonnant
arborescent où elle vit tout son désir
de vivre et d'exister et des mais je la
trouve absolument formidable de beauté
cette femme et puis elle a eu beaucoup
de courage à cette époque là elle était
quand même en exil avec son père et
toute sa famille sur l'île de de gerzat
puy de guernesey et elle a fait croire à
un moment donné où elle implose aide je
pense intérieurement où elle voulait
vivre
elle a fait croire qu'elle partait à
paris rejoindre sa mère est en fait elle
a pris le bateau traverser l'atlantique
et les partis en amérique ce qui est
complètement inconcevable pour une femme
à la fois de sa condition sociale mais
aussi à une époque où il fallait être
accompagnés pour voyager quand on était
une femme au 18ème siècle donc adèle
hugo avoir réussi à échapper à son père
c'est au fond une vraie
une vraie réussite c'est peut-être sa
réussite à elle d'avoir réussi à
échapper à la compréhension de son père
lui par ailleurs comprenez si bien les
août est ce que vous direz que cette
incompréhension sa rapport avec au four
des sociétés dans lesquelles tu étais
les hommes qui avaient le pouvoir
je ne sais pas ça dépend des époques
pour adèle hugo peut-être parce
qu'effectivement sa mère la comprenette
tout cas c'est amy winehouse
la société est en train de changer d
jamais vain mot oui c'est différent je
pense que ces hommes et femmes
quand quand on voit encore aujourd'hui
comment les gens dansent sur ses
chansons pourtant désespérée on danse
littéralement sur le mal-être d'amy
winehouse sur son chagrin
donc je pense oui que c'est pas du tout
lié à la virilité ou à la masculinité
c'est c'est à dire quand ceux désirant
produits de de vouloir tout savoir des
autres de vouloir absolument percer le
mystère trop les comprendre et au fond
ces femmes elles ont forgé forme et le
désir peut-être de disparaître et de
garder leur secret c'est très clair avec
emily dickinson qui choisit la réclusion
volontaire sans donner d'explication
elle s'enferme dans sa chambre pendant
des années mais c'est très clair aussi
pour quelqu'un comme effectivement
sylvia plath qui décide de se suicider
en soir après avoir couché ses enfants
il y as eu cette idée aussi de ne pas
vouloir ou tout donner aux autres et se
donner aux autres et je pense comme moi
c'est quelque chose qui m'a fait
beaucoup réfléchir parce qu'aujourd'hui
il est très difficile de le garder un
peu de soi de se préserver des autres et
du monde ou voilà où tout est si
facilement et à la bleue
instagram et des réseaux chacun des
maires c'est beaucoup maki donc ça
s'appelle les incombe récession globale
c'est michel lafon bardon juste en
mouvement rapide choisie ou si l on voit
là la sortie à quelques jours
d'intervalle des incomprise ce
magnifique recueil que vous avez
présenté dans une édition parue chez
gallimard traduit également plusieurs de
nouvelles donc wells où elle ce qu'on
connaît surtout en tant qu'auteur
spécialiste de l'anticipation les
visiteurs n'ont hélas il ya de l'amour
de la passion donc ways de l'amour
nouvelles et contes
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le rat
[Musique]